[Music]
when a let's talk about a new TV
miniseries after Camelot is the
follow-up to the controversial Kennedy
miniseries with Katie Holmes back as
Jacqueline Kennedy Onassis and Matthew
Perry joined us Ted Kennedy are Carly
still talked to both stars about playing
these iconic roles I'm really grateful
they're here picking up in the years
following JFK's death Ted Kennedy turns
to Jackie after his car crash at
Chappaquiddick Island which left
campaign staffer Mary Jo Kopechne II did
I think if something scares you a little
bit then you just head right into it
will also see Jackie's romance with
Greek billionaire Aristotle Onassis you
rescued me I've listened schepis what is
it about Jackie that made you want to
play her and take this role on again
they think that there were a lot of
interesting themes and wonderful parts
to her that I didn't get to portray
before so it was very challenging as an
actor but really rewarding and although
these two have a lot of heavy scenes
together katie has been an admirer of
matthew for a long time were you a big
fan of friends I was a huge fan
I remember going on the Warner Brothers
Studio tour we web by friends I was like
but nobody came out oh well
[Music]
you